[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
PAIGE BAILEY: I'm Paige
Bailey, a TensorFlow developer
advocate, and I'm here today
with Doug Stevenson, who's
going to tell us
all about the latest
and greatest in Firebase.
So show us what you
have planned, Doug.
DOUG STEVENSON: OK.
So turns out
Firebase has a bunch
of products that help
you ensure a high quality
of your app, which is very
important for a lot of app
developers.
Every app developer always has
to be able to diagnose crashes
in their app--
PAIGE BAILEY: Yes.
DOUG STEVENSON: --as you know.
So Firebase has a tool
called Crashlytics.
With Crashlytics, the
integration is fairly simple.
Add a plug-in, add a build
dependency to your build
and it just starts
monitoring crashes.
You don't have to write
any lines of code.
So the app is
crashing, you can see
that it's rather
problematic for our users.
But it turns out the
engineers made a good decision
and they put this new
home screen experiment
behind a Remote Config flag.
PAIGE BAILEY: So tell
me a little bit more
about what Remote Config is.
DOUG STEVENSON: Right.
So Remote Config lets you define
key value pairs in the Firebase
console and then you can
publish those to your app
without having to actually write
any lines of code in your app.
So it gets them all almost
immediately as you change them
in the console.
So the idea here is we
have a new parameter.
It's called home screen
experiment enabled,
and the default value is true.
So this is what's enabling
the new home screen
experiment that's also
causing devices to crash.
Now, what we want to do here
is ask our engineer and say,
our engineer thinks that
it's a translation issue.
So we've narrowed it down
to Spanish speakers who
are using the app on Android.
So we can define a new
condition here for this flag
and say for Spanish
speakers who are
using Android what
we can do is disable
the home screen experiment.
So we'll set it to
false for all of them
and all the other users
can retain the value true.
So, now, once this is
configured, what we'll do
is publish the store app,
and the app internally
will use Firebase Remote Config
to fetch parameters, pull out
that home screen flag,
and enable the home screen
experiment if it's been
enabled for this device.
PAIGE BAILEY: And it's
amazing that you're
able to narrow in with
such laser focus what
the problem could be, and then
to change it without altering
a single line of code.
DOUG STEVENSON: Right, right.
So it's remotely fixing
your app in some cases.
And we do recommend that
people publish their apps
with new features hidden
behind Remote Config flags,
so you can toggle them on
and off for cases like this.
PAIGE BAILEY: Right.
DOUG STEVENSON: So we'll
publish our new changes
to Remote Config.
We can see that the app
is no longer crashy.
PAIGE BAILEY: I see
no more sad faces.
DOUG STEVENSON:
No more sad faces,
and the number of crash
for users has gone up,
so we've reduced the crash
rate down to below 1%,
which is really good.
So a successful experiment.
PAIGE BAILEY: That's amazing.
So launch into the next demo.
What do we have next?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
So another thing that
developers need to be able to do
is compare what
their users prefer.
PAIGE BAILEY: A/B testing.
DOUG STEVENSON: Perform
an A/B test, yes.
So what we can do
is use Firebase A/B
testing to create and
run an experiment.
So what we can do
in the console here
is create an experiment
with a name targeting
half of our users with some
metrics that we want to track,
and we're going to use
Firebase Remote Config again
to configure this experiment.
So, for the control group,
dark mode will not be enabled.
And for the variant group, we
will enable this experiment.
So Remote Config as
it's going to tell
half the devices to run this
experiment and half the devices
not.
And we'll compare the metrics
on that and see how it performs.
PAIGE BAILEY: And all of this
is done through the console.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yes, all of this
So we can see here our
experiment is ready to run.
We're especially interested
in 15 day retention,
so we're going to use that
as the way to determine
whether or not this
experiment is successful.
So what we can do is
start this experiment.
Bear in mind that
Remote Config is
being used to pull
out that Boolean flag
and enable dark mode
only for those half
of all devices that are
configured to use it.
And what we're going to
do is run this A/B test,
and that's going to
push to our devices.
And, as you can see, some of our
devices are running dark mode
and some are running
light mode, and they're
switching between the two.
PAIGE BAILEY: I think I
like the light mode best.
DOUG STEVENSON:
You like the light?
OK.
I'm partial to dark mode but--
PAIGE BAILEY: Well, let's
see what the users say.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
The users get to decide
based on our goal metrics.
PAIGE BAILEY: Oh, man.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
It looks like dark mode
is the leader in this,
and we can see the exact
mark on the retention
that this experiment had.
PAIGE BAILEY: This is amazing.
I was a data scientist
in a previous life,
and, historically,
we would have to use
weeks of training and custom
code and configurations
and track all of the metrics
and visualizations ourselves.
But this looks like
you could do it
just by clicking a
couple of buttons.
DOUG STEVENSON: That
entire engine is basically
hidden by Firebase A/B testing.
So we can use Remote
Config and then push it out
to all of our users.
All right.
The last thing that a
lot of app developers
are concerned about--
PAIGE BAILEY: And it's probably
the most the most important
one.
DOUG STEVENSON: And
everyone wants their pages
to load fast and their
screens to be snappy.
So what we can do is measure
that with Firebase Performance
Monitoring.
Now with Firebase
Performance Monitoring,
you put basically
one SDK in your app
and it automatically
collects things.
And it goes out to
your users and it
measures the behavior of your
app on your user's devices.
But if you do need to measure
something in particular,
like say, the load screen
time, what you can do
is create a trace.
PAIGE BAILEY: And so,
tell me what a trace is.
DOUG STEVENSON: So
a trace is something
in Firebase Performance
Monitoring that measures
the duration of something.
So here we're creating a new
trace, we're starting a timer.
Then after we load
and all of our image
and text for this screen
we'll stop the timer.
That becomes our metric.
So that's going to get sent
to the Firebase Performance
Monitoring dashboard.
So we're going to run this code
on all of our users devices,
collect this metric,
and now you can
see here is the trend
over time is that 555
milliseconds of load time.
PAIGE BAILEY: That
is way too long.
DOUG STEVENSON:
It's half a second,
but it still feels
like an eternity
and when you click the button.
So what we need to do
is bring this down.
Now it turns out this
app has been configured
with Firebase Remote Config
to have a configurable image
quality.
So the idea is, to speed up
the performance for our app,
we'll ratchet down the quality.
Maybe that will make the images
smaller and faster to load.
So what we can do is
create a condition for this
and say that half of our
users get a reduced quality.
So, when we finalize
this, half of our users
are going to get the
default, the other half
are going to get this
reduced image quality.
And then we can compare
this in the dashboard.
Now, again, we do need
a few lines of code
to enable this in Remote Config.
When that's done, we can
collect this information
on our user's devices,
exactly as they're using it
and come up with results.
So we were able to reduce
the time to 111 milliseconds,
and our engineer thinks
this is a good idea.
PAIGE BAILEY: Much faster.
And I agree with them.
And it also looks like you
can drill down into the data
by device?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah, yeah.
So right now we're slicing
this by app version,
but you can also use
other characteristics
of the device and
the user to determine
what the performance is for
very specific conditions.
PAIGE BAILEY: That's amazing.
And I love being able to see
the visualizations just out
of the box.
So thank you so much for sharing
all of this great functionality
with Firebase.
I can't wait to try
out an A/B test.
DOUG STEVENSON:
Thanks for joining me.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]